assalamu alaikum warahmatullah care to
brothers and sisters in their friends
and there are non-muslims if you have
come on to our channel today you're
going to see Muslims reacting to
homosexuals or my sexuality same thing
so what we're gonna do is there's gonna
be you know you could even obviously you
guys might have a perception in your
head how it's gonna be but let's see if
that's how this is gonna turn out to be
you'll see what's goin on yeah we're
gonna watch two videos in Shaba yeah
we're gonna to videos I'm gonna react to
one is a man walking in New York City as
a homosexual fan and walking through all
[Music]
nice going over come on at least act
properly nice no honestly he's not
acting poor this is disrespectful to
homosexuals no no cuz look how he's
walking man come on at least like me you
know exaggerated yes what are you
looking like that for now that I've seen
it's like he's mocking
it might mean GTA no I've never had that
before it's Victoria's Secret no Victor
Road eyes that's all sure
oh you're just touching some next man
like it's happy dude how can we arrest
Minh
why are they going to a gay game whoa he
said 50% off where huh oh is that the
provision these are gonna discuss yeah
that's racist oh he did on purpose
did he good yeah purpose no Justin all
right
I thought I was only using the UK you
know that kind of led saying oh oh damn
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's all right it'll be funny if he
punched him just what up dog bang what's
crazy I would never thought done done to
a male or female bro like it's
disgusting 50-plus instances of verbal
visit within three hours stairs a gay
and lesbian teens are two to three times
more like to come on suicide okay
okay before we wanted quick quickly yeah
hey why see from this and I think that
all you guys should understand from that
is well it's sadly in today's time it's
made out to see we see like Muslims not
you know that Muslims are only this you
know homophobic you know like hate
homosexuals and this narrative is pushed
out there this is an American country
this is a country where freedom of
expression or whatever you want to do it
you can do it he's walking down the
street of New York City nuke city's
vibrant multicultural and look at the
harassment he's getting yet nobody
deserve to be harassed sure you're not
in that way know that that is actually
that's kind of sad you know yeah it's
really sad because no one wants to feel
like that so for them to be struggling
or something like that in in this in a
homophobic Society to be honest with you
yeah it must be hard for them on a day
to day let's watch our next video yes
because then we're gonna get an
understanding of this whole perception
of us Muslims towards homosexuals etc I
get to see a gay individual homosexual
individual walk down the street like
that I think that was it was exaggerated
yeah
oh he just he oh did you get that you
guys said he just said to him why why
would you go and act upon this and he
just said but I'm not so they went there
with the assumption that he acts upon
being a homosexual
the guy in the middle white he's a
Muslim revert also his name is Paul yeah
the person who's struggling with Trump
and then you've got two new moves and
reverts we're going to cover the face
when I'm going to show them how they
reacted a bit Trina
yeah that's a bit of fluid point saying
how can you be gay if you don't act upon
it because oh I got married and before I
was obvious obviously when you'll get
married you're sexually active to be
very blunt I was straight yes because I
wasn't acting and feelings very
interesting yes I have an ACCI so things
are that's very interesting
was he just said that the Sharia those
were the actions that you do not in
ragazza feelings and that's true because
that's I might be walking down the
street as a married man and I'm you know
though while lowering my gaze ago who's
Marshall are very pretty she catches my
eye
yes now if I if oh yes
but if a thought comes in my mind
because of that I'm not accountable for
that for ya said this one my is like the
force that we get if we don't act upon
them not sinful yeah and only that
because I [ __ ] on all ports and not only
that as Muslims if we believe it if we
have an evil for and you don't after
funny you get a reward Judaism
Christianity and Islam all believe that
homosexuality is a sin as a major sin
yes we believe that it's not denying
that
however Islam is the only one that says
you don't act according to the action
looking at a woman in a lot of man or a
man it's it's it's a sin yeah you should
you should know your game I don't know
why it's comparing it that's why I think
the village this conversation to me so
far has been pointless he has made it
clear where he's on which is that he
gets inclinations but he doesn't act on
them for example Allah says Maharaj's
created man weak we have witnessed
towards women yeah so sometimes if we
have Shaitan bring an evil force into
our head yeah if we don't act upon it
that's like you know wasn't it was a
difference me
me us men having tests but from woman
for you know it's very poor fun you know
you know where we profound if you don't
cut me as having for like for example
men having a weakness against woman is a
test same way a man might have a feeling
or a woman in my opinion against the
same gender yeah it's about leaving it
for the sake of God and saying you know
what I want to please God
yeah and I want paradise so this is a
test I'm gonna pay for it yes as a
Muslim looking at a woman or a man
lustfully is wrong
[Laughter]
so what are you talking about the
presentation it's like what you have in
Auckland because it's like you're just
trying to have a digging him because he
has these inclinations
you know of course like me having a
digger Ali for being ugly I can't blame
him
immigration of Allah is beautiful you
know advising people without knowledge
it just yes it just makes you look a bit
it makes you look and it just causes
destruction you end up destroying
people's Iman rather than say yes that's
what they like if Paul didn't have
knowledge like he probably would have
left yeah nobody thought he would have
been left nobody would have assumed that
all Muslims are like this yes you can't
say I'm a Muslim in me that's wrong you
can't say that there's this one minute
one minute
there's other people in Hyde Park here
who are propagating this shirk on an
active level yes actively yeah associate
partners of Allah yeah do these brothers
have as much Allah Allah will borrow
which is love and love love and hatred
for Allah to go and heat that more
because there it seems like they have
exactly because they always think this
shows a lack of tawheed lack of tawheed
middle understanding of oneness of God
so it just goes to show you I mean some
of us fail to understand the potential
of of non-muslims if today and
non-muslim that I'm speaking to accepts
Islam yeah as soon as he's accepted
Islam he's like a newborn baby
yeah all of his previous sins are
forgiven of corny as a Muslim I've got
loads of sins so that's what we'd fail
to understand then looking at
non-muslims we look down upon them yeah
non-muslim
is a potential
that's in the train I hope no one is
anything they need help their self
because sadly Paul is speaking more
Islamically he's right why is it bad you
can say the same thing it's we're
talking about a sin which is a sin
yeah it's like any other like major sin
it's a sin and the other is that you
turn around to and say bro look okay if
you're committing zina just know that
you're not watching it's the same thing
didn't and only that it's not just
Muslims it's not these two guys here
you've got a guy on the left and a guy
on the right which are non Muslim gay
roster hearing and other guys know he's
an atheist he has no moral glance to see
[Music]
look that's not just me saying look it I
know
adultery act and adultery is wrong
that's why I'm not gonna do adultery and
I'm gonna do the right thing until I'm
gonna stay away from me saying one
minute why do you get 40 minutes under
stun just because you get these force
doesn't mean you're homesick I don't
think there's one Muslim on the face of
this earth yeah that can tell me with
confidence that my brother I have never
had a thought from the shaitaan in my
head yeah
about anything about the Sahaba had bad
thoughts about a lot having these force
doesn't make you homosexual
do you get it because it's that seed you
know in my head I sometimes think about
murdering somebody doesn't make you a
murderer
yeah it's obviously it's wrong what
you're thinking it's about overcoming
that why for the love of God I don't
know what the benefit is of mentioning
that you are because then you are gonna
attract a lot of ignorant people like
this and they went up to him he didn't
come up that's the thing to be maybe
they heard from somewhere else I don't
know
[Music]
you know you know it's a very perform
point that he mentioned abdullah bin a
bus was actually of the view that you
know what the greatest sin is after
shirk drinking alcohol consuming alcohol
the purpose of a lot of saloons would
look for any excuse to keep someone as a
muslim now adays the muslims look for
any excuse to make someone yeah but the
thing is everyone since everyone's sins
are different everyone is going at their
own pace a finger-sized you know what
you just said yeah everyone sins like
thus that is accepted by everyone yeah
but you know the craziest thing is
they're not even talking about a sin
here they're questioning him and for
having thoughts if you have them desires
about woman that's you that's not me if
you wanna go and do that you go do that
I'm sorry
I suggest you do that somebody don't
tell anyone you didn't do anything I'm
just gonna assume the best because you
know what you mean assume the banana how
is this relevant no we don't have but
something is it to renew reverb profits
yeah we have to know I'll assume the
best yeah about them yeah no you have no
right to go to anybody and question
Amira are you doing this
yeah what is it slums position on being
a homosexual on active homosexual being
actively gay practicing the act of being
gay if some is against that and we're
here at Sunni Muslims we don't disagree
with that Islam is against us against
that we have an issue of the way that
tomecek someone that's what my sexual is
being treated yeah I mean look at you
when Alma phobic it's it's about you
can't go look it's look I can't go and
start looking down and the homosexual
like I can't go like me for in some I
might disagree with it
black people there's other people
actually saw that in the first video
that people don't agree with that saga
might say you know I think it's wrong
there's Christians the Jews which I say
this is absolutely wrong yeah however
you don't go and stop belittling and
swearing and insulted and treated
because look at what happened blue
Tulisa Lamia he came to those people at
that time now obviously we believe God
Almighty destroyed our nation the
actually said on what did he do what did
he say what did he say what did he do he
would give them and push to them and
seize him look you know except he would
offer solutions he will he also tourism
he gets for his own tortures in my he
said don't do this I marry my artist
yeah how many of us as brothers would go
to someone who has gained cognition I
tried to my door and help him the first
thing is we state the punishment that
was done we don't state what happens
before
I'll be honest even before today I
didn't know this is well yeah and then
you guys said this this is very very
profound offering the solution telling
someone to stop you know smoking
cigarettes you have to give them a
solution yes that tell them they sister
there's a session going on to take
patches take this thing that I mean in
Jamaica a caller was saying that
they're very homophobic in Jamaica but
the thing is that their majority
Christian nation or Rastafarians or
whatever no one ever says that it's
because it's written in the Bible it's
because it's in the teacher of the
roster yeah or Joe or whatever yeah no
one ever says that Nomad thing is people
will associate this behavior with Islam
it's got absolutely nothing to do with
it me yeah but do we now believe that we
can be talking a little bit in our
behavior yeah all right look at this
no this is not from the mannerisms or
profits or some ambivalence if if a gay
man came to the prophet sallallaahu them
and said o Messenger of Allah I need
help with this I am acting in this way
you think the brother son would turn
away from it solutions to be a solution
for
[Music]
[Music]
none of your business what is he saying
what is he here for sir ya fools no were
you talking about
okay are you telling me that you don't
have thoughts about females if someone
comes up to you and says oh I'm hooked
to this particular drug what are you
going to do stop judging them start
saying you know Muslim anymore
go and do what you're doing just don't
have thoughts of drugs and he said look
but I can't get rid of it I mean imagine
if it was a child yeah
the thing is with other people imagine
that this guy is your relative you would
speak to him differently you would do
anything to help them yes to you know
understand them understand don't
reprimand
he said one very important thing he's a
human being
yeah and the fact that you're a sinner
you still a human being broke like a
story of a companion you came to the
Prophet and asked permission to do zina
the problem didn't randomly start saying
oh you get in these thoughts why you get
in these days
he immediately he he understood him
reason he gave him that respect and then
he spoke to him in a reasonable manner
using logic
oh forget the mic you know you know not
the mic you know the sound system offers
everything he jumped a job everything in
the whole building let's just sum it up
here for non-muslims you're watching
maybe and for Muslims to understand this
well we're coming up from for Muslims
yeah yeah you have to understand that we
all have struggles yeah and when I say
struggles I'm not talking about sins I'm
saying we all struggle yeah we all have
faults we all have to control ourselves
your struggle watching this might be
music okay every day you might see your
friends listening to music and you're
not ah I can't like I really want to
listen to music yeah someone else Oh
struggle they might come from a
background where they would come in a
lot of Zinner that might be Zenor for
them okay yeah someone else might come
from a musical background really used to
make music that might be a fitness for
him
I know brothers like this in all of
these different scenarios I've mentioned
and then someone might come from a
background where they were gay and they
were acting upon that they became Muslim
and now they can't keep acting upon that
there is no difference between all of
these situations all of these situations
are sins
and it's people struggling to not act
upon since since place in suspect Bosnia
don't judge somebody just because they
seem differently than you yeah that's
not yours or someone else I said that
before
I'm pretty sure someone else' said that
before and finally it's a major quality
right so just a quick wrap-up for non
non-muslim mobile sex shows and those
Muslim homosexuals we have those
tendencies is that look it's your
struggle you're gonna be accountable to
God this is what we believe in our
religion and like I said before it's the
same thing as somebody have an
inclination towards woman so if your
non-muslim yes you can become a Muslim
you can become a Muslim yes you should
try to stop the act
yeah because it is a major sin and
that's about it guys hope you guys are
benefited and hope you have really
understood as a Muslim how we react on
the site follow me on instagram follow
me on youtube subscribe to me and my
Instagram and please next time
Salam alaikum